hokey-pokey and new-agey but I'm trying
to do so I'm gonna do yoga I haven't
done it yet but I'm gonna do it hoo hoo
hoo hoo I don't know yet know if you're
doing yoga could you do some muy Thai
with us let him start with yoga first
who doesn't more time more grounding
thing and he needs to ground a fine yoga
who's doing more time with you like me
and like David and something even
wanting to come out a koala - yeah I can
only do Anderson Silva like I want to
get trained by the legit sorry Nick only
Anderson's Nick Nick the guy with the
big ears he's a fighter and trainer Oh
Nick Diaz I'll do it from Nick Diaz he
knows Nick the ear baby Oh big fan big
fan boy boy boy my morning it's Georgia
stress if you want a lot e like George I
mean are you guys going strong you and
your woman congratulations I'm very
happy for you
he has intercourse it seems strange but
why does it bother you so much it
doesn't bother me I'm trying to get my
mind right we're on it it's strange but
pure what you mean of course is Harvey
in weird ways but I would still call it
intercourse yes and of course because
it's going into something in something
okay yeah it's your beautiful vagina is
what I wanted to say really to be honest
with you yeah I've been doing the know
you know what so very been difficult
very difficult very bit difficult what
what I know I just wanted to say clearly
you know what's been very difficult for
me is I'm trying to I'm no I'm not
watching porn so I'm trying to
masturbate through my mind you know so
but when I'm masturbating sometimes I
think of porn is that wrong no I'm gonna
admit something I used to think that
that's what I wanted for you like that
you know you just masturbate from
imagination but then somehow it makes me
more insecure and it hurts my feelings
thinking that you would imagine
real people versus
sports stars like that's a legitimate
fear of mine I'm like oh he's pulling
from his real life now real life
archived versus you know just looking at
random like no-name a gold film stars
right but his imagination is pulling
from you oh you think you out of your
mind that's not feasible
hey Macau no baby of course I love you
and you're very sexy don't cover your
face you look very beautiful but you
know the world your face come on baby
let's show the world 2020 okay I love
you come on baby
I'm doing it for us I you know I'm I'm
not watching porn for expect that
because it's uh and I think you know
these women that do porn there's a lot
of trauma that they went through some of
them know but for the most part yes you
know you have your anomalies and
exceptions but Allah and also I've made
it an agreement not to go to strip clubs
even though I haven't yeah um I'm just
not gonna even think about going I have
thought about going like if I'm on the
road and like you know let's go to baby
dolls in my mind I'm like I'm too tired
or whatever but that's not even options
because you know these women that not
all of them but a lot of them that work
in these the these women that have
suffered a lot of pain and some of them
have drug use and some of them it's just
not healthy you know sorry